here with reaction former trump chief of
staff mark meadows along with former
senior adviser
to president trump stephen miller mark
meadows we start with you
look socialism always fails the new
green deal would always fail getting rid
of energy independence
would always fail open borders amnesty
will fail
now you see how the world is not showing
well joe any respect that's scaring me
well it's scaring me too i talked to
president trump this afternoon and
when we looked at what's happening in
the job market the fact that you have
more help
wanted signs out than perhaps is healthy
for
the economy i can tell you where we need
a help wanted sign
it's at 1600 pennsylvania avenue they
need some help and some decision makers
there because they're not in control of
the border
they're not in control of the job market
they're not in control
of our international relationships with
china and russia
and quite frankly they're not even in
control of their own narrative as they
put it up
to leave congresswoman to leave is
talking about shutting down dhs but yet
at the same time
they're talking about we're going to
hire new irs agents
or perhaps send people door to door to
check on vaccines
i mean come on it it it is just beyond
belief that progressive would go this
far to the left that quickly
and what is the net result of this where
do you see this going stephen miller
no president in history has been dealt a
better hand on day one
than president biden think about what
president trump left him and what it's
become
he left him a middle east that was at
the dawn of a new piece
the most secure border in american
history energy abundance we had more
energy than we knew what to do with we
had an economy that was primed to roar
we had a viable path towards a peace in
afghanistan
all of this and more was left at the
doorstep for joe biden
and what do we have we have cities out
of control with crime we have open
borders
we have the middle east in tatters we
have afghanistan falling to pieces
we have an economy with massive
inflation runaway spending
and we have jobs that should be filled
not to be filled
but unwise fiscal stimulus policy is
keeping workers out of the workforce
this is a disaster where is it leading
sean it's leading to
an era of malaise suffering
and economic stagnation low wages
high unemployment and massive crime
coming across our border and staying in
our cities
let me ask you this the trafalgar
convention of states poll that came out
this week mark
um 57 percent of americans don't think
joe's in charge
58 of independents a third of democrats
don't think he's running the show
um pretty amazing because outside of
this little one hour we have here and a
couple of other hours
on fox and some of us in talk radio the
rest of the media is hiding joe's
cognitive struggles
what would that number be if the media
did their job and actually
showed america how bad this is
deteriorating
well i i think the economy is already
showing the signs that no one's in
charge and
if you really looked at an accurate poll
and if the broader spectrum of of the
media
would actually cover this what you would
see is is the tough questions
fail to get answered by joe biden and
when he tries to answer them
he really stumbles all over his words
you know if it's something
more difficult than his favorite uh
uh color or or actually a flavor of ice
cream he has a real tough time
answering it and so what we we do know
is that indeed stephen is exactly right
he was dealt a great hand all he had to
do is sit in the oval
office and allow much of this to go on
autopilot
and instead what he's done is put
progressive socialist
policy in place that is harming the
american people
and stephen you got china they're
talking about reunification
i can't imagine them saying this with
taiwan
uh uh well right now i wouldn't have
said it under president trump you know
that sean
they wouldn't because they had he would
they had a fear and respect
they feared donald trump and they
respected him whether you're talking
about the taliban whether you're talking
about the drug cartels whether you're
talking about the communist regime
in china they're all on the march
they're all on the run
because they don't respect this
president they don't respect this
administration and they know
that no one is in charge and in fact
they know that these socialist
marxist policies are going to lead to a
steep american decline if not reversed
liberals won't believe me mark meadows i
wish i was wrong and
pointing out that this guy is a
cognitive mess i really do for the sake
of the country and frankly the sake of
the world
but under donald trump i can't imagine
that
the chinese would be talking about
reunification with taiwan
i can't imagine the chinese and russians
applying the
iranians weapons to fight their proxy
wars in the middle east
i can't imagine under donald trump that
iran would have the guts to start
uh the enrichment of uranium once again
i can't imagine any of those things
happening because i think they feared
donald trump
well they did fear him and they had
every right to because he was willing to
call them out
you know and we've gone on this apology
tour once again
abroad this appeasement tour
and appeasement never works our enemies
respect
power and that's what donald trump would
show them and they're getting exactly
the other you know they're they're
getting a tulip and a carnation
instead of tough rhetoric and yet the
progressives were all afraid that donald
trump was going to lead us
into a war and exactly the opposite
happened we had a more peaceful middle
east as stephen pointed out
under president trump than ever before
because he understood peace through
strength he could bring our boys home
from overseas
because we were strong they were
offended by us
and we need to be welcoming these men
and women who are coming home from
afghanistan
we need to say welcome home jim needs to
walk that back
yeah and maybe we should we welcome them
maybe we should have logistically
planned to take our weaponry out of
there before they left instead of giving
it to the taliban
uh that's about as dumb as their nuclear
deal with iran thank you both mark
meadows stephen miller
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else